[Musique]
vous ne pouvez reporter sans cesse
signer dié la réouverture des musées et
des monuments la reporter sans cesse
réinventé la saint glinglin politique d
confiner ces lieux de culture
arrêtez de vitrifier l'accès aux oeuvres
d'art au joyau du patrimoine
il ne nous reste que les écrans cela ne
peut plus durer
des confiner les musées et les monuments
mais c'est le premier ministre la france
pays de la gastronomie voit depuis le
début de l'épidémie
ces restaurants fermés avec des
conséquences économiques et sociales
dramatiques les restaurants espaces de
liens sociaux par définition sont
supposés être des foyers de
contamination du virus
pourtant rares sont les études
scientifiques qui permettent de le
démontre la france ne devrait-elle pas
porter l'initiative d'une étude
scientifique à ce sujet vous avez
annoncé en juin dernier
douze mille lits seraient disponibles en
cas de besoin ou son celi nous savons
qu'aucun lit de réanimation n'a été
ajoutée au lit déjà existant est
simplement un coup de communication
comme mes collègues je rencontre
régulièrement les maires de mon
département
ils nous interpellent actuellement sur
les éventuelles fermetures de classes
sans leur avis entre les inspecteurs
d'académies et recteurs les secrétaires
d'état et vous même les discours
divergent en juillet 2010 est à peine
élu le président macro nombreuses
promettait qu'il n'y aurait plus de
fermetures de classes dans les écoles
primaires rurales
pourtant dès février 2018 le
gouvernement décide et d'importants
fermeture pour la rentrée suivante
nouveau revirement vous même monsieur le
ministre sur tf1 le 27 mars dernier
prométhée qu'il n'y aurait aucune
fermeture de classe en milieu rural dans
une école primaire
sauf accord explicite des mers ait voulu
justifier très logiquement par les
circonstances exceptionnelles liées à la
crise sanitaire
or on nous annonce de multiples
fermetures à la rentrée prochaine
et ceci dans toute la france nous
parlons d'une jeunesse désoeuvrée
esseulé avec un horizon rétrécit nous
parlons d'un mal être profond
nous parlons d'idées suicidaires de rêve
qui s'effondrent les questions concrètes
sont nombreuses face à la dégradation
des conditions d'enseignement
allez vous garantir la valeur des
diplômes pourquoi ne pas avoir prévu de
report des conventions pour pouvoir
faire son stage ultérieurement en france
ou à l'étranger
pourquoi ne pas avoir créé à l'image du
fonds de solidarité un fonds étudiant
pour tous les jeunes qui ne trouvent pas
de petits boulots
cette année alors qu'il en avait un
avant la crise votre action ne peut pas
laisser de côté tout un pan de la
jeunesse le week-end dernier une énième
zone à défendre une zad s'est une
nouvelle fois installées en toute
illégalité sur des terrains appartenant
à l'état sur des emprises dédié à
l'aménagement de la zac du triangle de
gonesse dans le val d'oise
j'avais demandé à monsieur le premier
ministre de nous rassurer sur sa volonté
à expulser et j'ai entendu madame la
ministre
pompili demander gentiment aux
délinquants de partir tranquillement je
suis rassuré madame la ministre
la vulnérabilité cyber dans notre pays
en fait une proie facile pour les
hackers c'est une menace de tout premier
ordre
que comptez vous faire pour que nos
entreprises et nos services publics puis
se prémunir de ce risque
voilà la crise le logement c'est un
sujet fondamental pour tous nos
concitoyens nous sommes dans une impasse
vous pouvez vous avez encore le temps de
bouger sur les exos tfpb mais également
sur l'article 55 de la loi sru fait le
mal à beaucoup de maires sont prêts à
construire il faut les y aider ça n'est
pas seulement les coups de bâton qu'il
faut ils font les accompagner alors
faites le de grasse
faites-le les chiffres de l'insécurité
dans notre pays se dégrade et il en est
un qui inquiète tout particulièrement
les français c'est celui qui résulte de
la constitution de bandes
particulièrement dans les parties
urbaines ou périurbaines
de notre territoire pouvons nous compter
sur vous pour intervenir auprès du
président de la république et qu'enfin
molière reposent parmi les grands hommes
au panthéon
[Musique]